the sharp edge of these issues I've been
following him now on social media time
to introduce him to you if you have not
yet met him Muhammad thanks for joining
us and congratulations on some uh great
work uh including
schooling uh the
multi-millionaire uh Pierce Morgan on
the multi-billionaire rert Murdoch's uh
television uh show tell us first of all
what that was
like well thank you for that and I
wanted to actually congratulate you as
well um for your inac indacil the words
that you use all the time and your
resilience in fact your patience and
your courage on this issue on the
Palestine issue I think that um you the
community has noted the community has
noted that you have been a close Ally on
these matters and we really respect uh
your work on the Palestine issue I think
that your work in the last 20 years is
probably in the United Kingdom context
the most notable work and your
resilience and strength against some of
the far right elements of our society
has also been noteworthy so I wanted to
put that to
you second thing in terms of PE thank
you yeah in terms of peers I I I would
categorize him as a person who is um who
has heavy hands but a a glass jaw in the
sense that if you really put him if you
ask him questions if you you know in a
corner he will find it difficult to
answer the questions that he likes to
ask everybody else um and the reason for
that is is simply because he he he
doesn't actually have he's not morally
consistent he's only strategically
consistent you mentioned yourself his uh
kind of connections with Rupert Murdoch
and uh all these kinds of organizations
that he's worked with now it has been
said that the the reason why he's acting
in this way and he can't bring himself
to condemn the killing of civilians in
Gaza the most one of the most populated
areas in the world with civilians is
because he knows that that will G the
skin of his his Masters uh which shows
lack of backbone it shows lack of
Integrity uh that he's not integrous
he's not morally um principled in that
manner uh and in fact it shows that he's
he's not he doesn't have a moral compass
uh and that anyone could uh maybe give
him money uh to say whatever he they
want him to
say I'm afraid that's true but you put
them behind the eightball uh As
Americans uh who play that vulgar game
of pool uh will recognize uh you snooker
them as we would say in the United
Kingdom uh when you turn the question
round you asked him will you condemn the
Israeli defense Force killing of
thousands of Palestinian children and he
couldn't even answer
that exactly no I mean he hasn't even
answered that even after that uh
interview and the reason why it's it's
very clear for anyone to know and see is
because of his ideological and or
financial uh commitments I mean if we're
being honest about the situation right I
mean if we say that killing a child I
mean this is a very simple argument I
mean we can make it killing a child with
a Palestinian or Jewish Arab or Jewish
or black or white whatever it may be is
a bad thing okay H so killing one black
child killing one white child is is is
equally bad killing one Palestinian
child killing one Jewish child is
equally bad then it would make sense
then using that kind of logic that the
more children that you kill the worse it
is and so the IDF has been killing more
children therefore they've been they're
worse than any um anyone else in in this
conflict whether whether wants one wants
to invoke Hamas orah or any other entity
Islamic Jihad if we're talking about the
killing of Civilian death there's no
doubt that there's been more you've
mentioned it before I came on civilian
deaths that have been killed from the
Palestinian side and historically from
the disengagement in 2006 of of
Palestine the so-call disengagement
because in fact they've still maintained
effective military control in in
international Rel in international law
terms um in 2006 all these operations
that they've conducted from castled
protective Edge and every 3 to four
years what they call mowing the lawn or
killing the people or subduing the
populations there if we're just counting
bodies effectively if we're just
counting bodies there's no way anyone
can make an argument if you believe that
the human life of a child who is a Jew
and the human life of a child as an Arab
is equal that baby is equal to that baby
this race is equal to this race there's
no one no way anyone can make an
argument that in fact um that any other
party other than the IDF is is most
criminal here
now uh when I started uh in this cause
in
1975 precisely uh you could have fitted
all of the people who were ready to say
they were with the PLO uh into this room
that I'm sitting in which is not very
large and room for an elephant at the
back of it uh at the wor store of times
uh now hi Park could not contain all of
the British people who want to take to
the streets and demonstrate their
support for Palestine and if you add
those they left at home who can't or
won't go on demonstrations and so on now
we are millions and millions in the
United Kingdom and we are now
producing uh as if from
nowhere uh people of the
eloquence of you and the courage of you
and there are many of you now I'm seeing
them not least on on Piers Morgan I mean
low key uh I mean he's United Nations
class he's world class uh and you know
when I first knew him he was a rapper uh
now he's a political Statesman in other
words what I'm saying is we're growing
uh in in quantity but we're also growing
in quality and new leaders new speakers
like you are coming forward you've
expressed uh similar uh thoughts I saw
today uh and made the point that it is
causing some consternation amongst the
establishment that people they bring on
maybe thinking there'll be a punch bag
turn out to be brilliantly eloquent and
informed this is new isn't
it absolutely first of all thank you for
all the compliments I I really do uh
appreciate them the new God cannot have
done what they're doing unless the old
God uh which is people like yourself and
fact done what they done and it's no
doubt in my mind I remember being a you
know a child in in secondary school or a
teenager and uh and seeing your coverage
and your responses for example to the
2006 war in Lebanon and the way you
there was particular reporter that you
really put on the back foot doing
exactly the same things and techniques
that I've employed so once again I thank
you for all the compliments but um I
have to put to you as well that you've
laid the foundations actually for this
which shows you the importance of
intergenerational work in terms of the
PLO I think it's good that you mention
them because the PLO it really represent
an organization that have tried with the
peace talks and that have tried going
through you know the Oslo Accords and
these kind of things and lo and behold
what we're finding is that the
Palestinian issue
even though there have been nonviolent
attempts to try and resolve the
situation have not found resolutions I
mean we talk about the Oslo call but
people don't realize because now Hamas
for example is being used as a scapegoat
that there are for example the West Bank
is bereft of Hamas there is no Hamas in
the West Bank they have no uh effect
there at all and yet and we have the
Palestinian Authority there which the
PLO was part of and then became the PA
um still you have 44 children being
killed in this year alone according to
un reports children before the conflict
emerged and so what we're seeing is
Palestinian life is is being is being
cheapened by by people uh in this
country is being uh it's being seen as
lesser than and in fact I think this is
what we're we're facing we're facing
actually you talked about race before
you came on there was a segment talking
about your own anti-racial politics I
have to put you that I think that if you
believe in an apartheid system which
many people are saying we support Israel
and these kind of things I don't know to
what extent they support Israel because
if they support Israel unequivocally and
comprehensively and in everything that
they do then they should Al they they
would be implic complicit in supporting
Israel in their racism as well and there
it's an apartheid system not just
according to Human Rights Watch and Bets
Salem and Amnesty International and even
bodies of the UN but if you look at the
law because in 1973 there was a the UN
had an apartheid convention and of of
the things condition there was eight
conditions that were laid down one of
the conditions that were laid down for
something to be called apartheid is that
it would have to be it would have to
have laws that discriminate on the basis
of race if one just takes one example
which is the right of return law the
Aliyah it effectively says you have the
right to return if you're if you're a
Jew okay and if you convert by the way
to Christianity or to Islam
uh that right of return is actually uh
is relinquished or it's rescinded or
whatever it may be and so you lose the
right to return if you convert this is
just this example alone which no one can
deny because it's entrenched within the
the the statute books of Israeli law
this example alone it shows you clearly
that Israel is an apartheid state just
in the same way as a South Africa was in
fact there's a very good book that was
written on this uh topic about the
secret um Allegiance between all between
South Africa and and Israel the point
being here is that you have people like
P Morgan who claim to be anti-racist you
have people across the political
Spectrum who but then they talk about
supporting Israel unequivocally and I
don't see how that actually works how
does it work when you've got when you've
got communities of people Palestinian
people who are being imprisoned in the
West Bank without any you got CH you got
a thousand children in prisons in the
West Bank I mean you have um you have
children being killed as we've mentioned
we have all we have Gaza we have a
blockade going on and there's a reason
why Gaza and the West Bank are not part
of uh an Israeli State not that we're
proposing a one-state solution but that
this should be put on the table that if
Gaza with a 2.2 million population and
West Bank with a 3.2 million population
of uh Arabs were consumed into an
Israeli State you'd have a majority of
Arabs actually in Israel and if you have
a knesset which has a PR system with
proportional representation then they
couldn't they couldn't do this so in
order to try and subjugate the
Palestinians they can't have them as
part of the state they can't have a
two-state solution so they effectively
have to have them between two uh
situations a uh situation A is they
can't be part of the state and situation
B is they can't have their own statehood
so here this is if not apartheid even
worse than actually a parti because I
don't think South Africa had this state
of affairs where you know 10 ,000 people
were killed in 22 days in this in this
way and so people that are on this side
of history that they're talking about
supporting Israel's right to defend
itself and and that's all they're
talking about and they won't even bring
themselves like peers to condemn Israel
I have to ask the question I mean how
could you support how could it be
conceivable how is it intelligible how
is it conceivable how is it conceptually
possible to believe to support
unequivocally a state like
Israel and and not to to be racist
because
to to to be an apartheid supporter is it
not a prerequisite to be a racist that
you believe it's legitimate to
discriminate on the basis of race and I
think this should be the new narrative
the new narrative should be if if one
has unequivocal support and that is a
big conditional because not many people
have unconditional support but if people
have unconditional support to the state
of Israel they should be questioned
about whether or not they actually are
racist
people well the leader of the labor
party the leader of Her Majesty's
opposition
used exactly your word unequivocal my
support for Israel is unequivocal and
that same person uh sir kid stara uh
said that Israel had the right to cut
off water electricity and food from the
occupied territories and he is a king's
councel you couldn't get a more senior
lawyer than him now unless he's
masquerading as a lawyer he obviously
knew that Israel did not have the right
to do this that to do this would be
unequivocally
illegal but he still supported them and
he's the leader of the labor
party I have seen him come out and try
and retract some of those statements or
try and clarify them but you're right in
the first instance it was quite clear
what he said on LBC Radio and this is a
scandal if if anything could be said
about it at all it's it's a scandalous
State of Affairs for someone like Kama
who's by the way I mean in terms of the
Muslim population um cancelled um ifar
events that he had in in Ramadan he has
shown the cold cold shoulder to the
Muslim Community uh complete disrespect
I can't see how anyone would from the
Muslim Community after this would vote
for him or vote for his party he's
really alienated the Muslim Community
and with this his support as you
mentioned using the term unequivocal
that I would question him on this very
matter i' say look there's laws that are
entrenched we're not even talking about
issues that can be disputed like for
example
the Musta the the hospital in Gaza where
they said that that was misfiring of
this or that which is a ridiculous
proposition anyway but these things
there's a level of let's say um
insignificant doubt that one one can
employ but when we talk about laws which
are entrenched and one can refer to them
they're digitized and they're online
like the the right of return the
property the absentee property laws
which allow a disproportionate ability
for for example uh Israeli Jewish people
in in in West Bank and other places to
effectively seize property that would
otherwise be for Arab people the
settlements and these kind of things
which have been consistently said to be
um against international law and then
after that the killing of civilians and
the war crimes that have been committed
which go against Geneva four which go
against all kinds of principles in
international law if people can't speak
up about these kind of things we must
question their integrity we must
question whether or not they they're
racist because I say is I I want to know
how it's possible if AP partide is
defined as discrimination or at least
the prerequisite of it is discrimination
based on race how could it be possible
for a people to support a state which is
effectively an apartheid state without
having as a prerequisite of that an
except
legitimization of uh racial poit or
racism racism in politics or racism in
in in in law so they should be
questioned and I think this is a way in
which um we will separate the men from
the boys directly I mean how do you
support these AP pareed laws or do you
condemn them and that's another question
we can ask them can you do you support
the the right of return which is only
for Jewish do you support the the laws
on uh for example property which which
are discriminatory to Arabs do you
support the settlements do you support
the war crimes you because once again
all these things show that the the
international establishment is moving
towards uh racism effectively which is
cheapening the lives of the Palestinian
people comparative to uh Jewish people
and this is I think actually
scandalous mamad did job you've been
marvelous I knew you would be thanks for
joining us